können schnell gucken auf den nächsten
und heute letzten Tagesordnungspunkt im
Deutschen Bundestag eine Aktuelle Stunde
und in der wird es sich drehen um die
Vorgänge die wir in den vergangenen
Tagen ja man kann sogar sagen Wochenend
lützerath erlebt haben es ist eine
Aktuelle Stunde die auf Antrag der
afd-fraktion hier zustande kommt und sie
trägt den Titel lützerath Angriff auf
den Rechtsstaat
Hintergrund sind natürlich die
Demonstrationen die es um den bereits
geräumten oder zumindest weitgehend von
den ursprünglichen Bewohnerinnen und
Bewohnern geräumten Ort lützerath im
rheinischen Braunkohlegebiet ähm in
Nordrhein-Westfalen gegeben hat in den
vergangenen Tagen erst das Redner ist
der klimapolitische Sprecher der AFD
Fraktion Karsten Hilse
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
liebe Landsleute in der letzten Woche
erhielten die Bürger eine Lehrstunde die
massenmanipulationen durch Leitmedien
funktioniert in Dauerschleife wurde auf
der Nachrichtensendern live aus
lützerath berichtet in dem schon lange
keinen Bewohner mehr anwesend war nur
noch klimaterroristen hatten sich in den
Häusern verschanzt und sahen der
Konfrontation mit der polizeifreudig
entgegen diese verabschiedungswürdigen
Gestalten bewaffneten sich nicht nur mit
Wurfgeschossen Stein und Pyrotechnik
sondern auch mordwerkzeugen sogenannten
Molotow-Cocktails das Werfen von Molotow
Cocktails auf Polizisten für die
Verbrecher nur Schweine in Uniform ist
mindestens versuchter Totschlag weil der
Tod ist Opfers billigend in Kauf
genommen wird nach meiner
Auffassung handelt es sich hier sogar um
versucht Mord der niedere Beweggründe zu
unterstellen sind diese potenziellen
Mörder als Aktivisten zu verharmlosen
ist ein Schlag ins Gesicht aller
Einsatzkräfte ich weiß dass es auch
Menschen gibt die aufgrund der
tagtäglichen Indoktrination wirklich
daran glauben dass uns eine
Klimakatastrophe erteilt auch wenn
dieser Glaube vollkommen irrational ist
lediglich befeuert durch die falschen
Weltuntergangs Propheten die meisten
dieser verstrahlten demonstrieren
friedlich aber diejenigen die deren
denen schwerste Verletzungen oder gar
der Tod des Gegenübers vollkommen egal
ist oder diesen sogar herbeiführen
wollen sind potentielle Mörder absurder
wird es noch wenn sich grüne Kommunismus
aus dem Bundestag mit diesen Verbrechern
solidarisieren an welcher lichterloh
brennenden Hanfplantage muss man
vorbeigelaufen sein um hier im Bundestag
für den Abriss zu stimmen dieser der
letzten Häuser und dann nach NRW zu
fahren um sich mit diesen potenziellen
fordern gemein zu machen pure Heuchelei
und natürlich gab es auch ein ständig
einen mit der vielfliegerin neue Luisa
Neubauer in dem am erst Asperger-Syndrom
leidenden bedauernswerten Mädchen beide
ließen sich für ihre
unterbelichteten Fans Medien wirksam ein
paar Meter durch den Schlamm tragen und
machten sich so dann wieder auf in die
wohlbehütete und gut beheizte Villa von
Mama und Papa das bedauernswerte Mädchen
weiß es wohl nicht besser aber die
verwöhnte Göre die niemals in ihrem
Leben hungern oder frieren musste die
das Geld verprasst dass ihre Vorfahren
vor allem durch Unterstützung der
Nationalsozialisten anhäuften ist Teil
der großen Inszenierung vom
vermeintlichen heroischen Kampf gegen
geldgierige Konzerne dass die Villa von
Mama und Papa kalt wird wenn diese
Konzerne keinen Strom und keine Wärme
mehr liefern geht über den Horizont
dieser geistigen tiefliger wie
beschreibt Albert Einstein doch so
trefflich diese Menschen Zitat manche
Menschen haben haben einen geistigen
Horizont mit Radius 0 und das nennen sie
dann ihren Standpunkt Zitat Ende und
natürlich haben die klimaextremisten
also die potenziellen Mörder von
lützerath und die klebstoffsüchtigen
verkehrsbremsen nicht nur eingeschränkte
kognitive Fähigkeiten sondern überhöhen
sich auch noch moralisch selbst und die
Straftaten die sie begehen mit den guten
Zweck zu begründen das ist es was
Kommunisten und Sozialismus in allen
ihren Ausprägungen immer getan haben
unter dem Motto der Zweck heiligt die
Mittel haben sie den Menschen eine
bestimmte Lebensweise aufgezwungen ihre
Freiheit eingeschränkt und im
schlimmsten Fall ermordet um das here
Ziel zu erreichen deswegen haben
klimatterroristen auch kein schlechtes
Gewissen wenn die wenn wie bei der
Radfahrerin die von einem LKW überrollt
wurde Menschen sogar zu Tode kommen das
nenne ich Menschenverachtung pur nun ist
es natürlich legitim und laut
Grundgesetz auch das gute Recht jedes
Menschen friedlich zu demonstrieren wenn
aber diejenigen die für Frieden Freiheit
Selbstbestimmung auf die Straße gehen
spezialisiert und diffamiert werden
Ihnen absurderweise Rechtsextremismus
oder gar antisemitis Semitismus
angedichtet wird gleichzeitig
potenzielle Mörder als Aktivisten
verharmlost werden ist das ein
medienpolitischer Skandal ohne Gleichen
natürlich kommen der von den Grünen
Kommunisten geführten Bundesregierung
derlei Aktionen sehr gelegen den
Rezipienten von der Leitmedien wird so
weiß gemacht dass politische
Handlungsdruck bestünde die selbst
initiierten Kompromisse zum Beispiel den
Kohlekompromiss für nichtig zu erklären
die Klima Extremisten wollen natürlich
gar keinen Kompromiss sondern ihre
Maximalforderungen durchsetzen aber
selbst wenn sie einen Kompromiss
eingehen ist dieser komplett wertlos da
sie diesen bei nächster Gelegenheit
wieder aufkündigen ein Kompromiss mit
grünen Kommunisten ist das Papier nicht
wert auf dem dieser niedergeschrieben
wird das sollten vor allem denen klar
sein die sich mit ihnen im
parlamentarische Bettchen legen der
einzige Weg zurück zu vernünftiger
Energiepolitik ist konsequent
vernunftgeleite der Politik und die gibt
es im Moment nur mit der AFD ich hoffe
dass die CDU irgendwann ihren
merkelismus überwindet und wieder zu
konservativer Politik zurückkehrt
schönes Wochenende
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Hilse nächster
Redner ist der Kollege Sebastian Fiedler
SPD-Fraktion und Sebastian Fiedler ist
in der SPD-Fraktion Sprecher für
Kriminalpolitik
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
interessierte es ist bei einem Antrag
eben nicht egal ob bei einer aktuellen
Stunde von wem sie kommt und wenn wir
eine Situation haben wo die
Rechtsausleger meines Erachtens die
Rechtsextremen sich über linksextreme
austauschen dann ist gut wenn aus der
Mitte das ganze so ein bisschen
eingeordnet wird denn wir haben ja
sozusagen so ein Beispiel erlebt es ist
schon irgendwie ein bisschen krass wir
haben mit der Rechtsstaat in der
Überschrift auftaucht und diejenigen
große Belastung und Problem für den
Rechtsstaat sind sich ausgerechnet dazu
äußern das muss ich schon sagen danke
aber wir wissen ja auch in ist das
ziemlich egal was hier am Podium erzählt
wird sie wollen viele Klicks erreichen
das haben Sie vielleicht jetzt
möglicherweise wieder hingekriegt
herzlichen Glückwunsch ich will ein paar
Sätze sagen zu lützerath und will das
ein bisschen einordnen und will nicht
nur über diejenigen die in der Vielzahl
friedlich demonstriert haben sondern
will ein paar Sachen einordnen das
hauptsächlich tut dass der
nordrhein-westfälische Landtag ist das
nicht so ganz unsere Spielwiese aber ich
will auf ein paar Aspekte durchaus auch
eingehen weil die gesagt gehören es gab
durchaus Brände Barrikaden Würfe mit
Pyrotechnik Farbbeutel Steinen Flaschen
und Molotowcocktails auf Polizistinnen
und Polizisten Mitarbeiter von RWE es
gab unglaublich dämliches und
lebensmüdes Verhalten an der
Abbruchkante weil es halt so eine
gefährlich gewesen ist weil sie
abstürzen konnte das Pferd an der
Polizei Reiterin wurde aufgeht sie
musste abspringen um sich zu retten über
100 verletzte Polizisten sehr strittige
zahlen wie viel das auf der anderen
Seite gewesen sind alles in Menschen
deswegen wünsche ich von dieser Stelle
allen gute und schnelle und vollständige
Genesung
mein Mitgefühl ist allerdings offen
gestanden mehr bei den Polizistinnen und
Polizisten weil ich zu den wenigen
gehöre die sich erinnern können wie es
ist in Uniform Leuchtspur Geschosse und
Steine um die Ohren zu kriegen nach all
dem was wir wissen hat die Polizei was
den Einsatz angeht und was wir aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen hören ganz guten
Einsatz gemacht wie das sich mit dem
Innenminister verhält wissen wir noch
nicht da wird der Landtag glaube ich gut
drauf gucken weil wir wissen dass der
Innenminister derjenige ist der mit dem
Einsatz am Hambacher Forst den größten
rechtswidrigen Polizeieinsatz der
Geschichte des Landes zu verantworten
hatte darauf darf man glaube ich noch
mal hinweisen das sagt nicht nur ich
sondern das Verwaltungsgericht Köln
schauen wir aber ein Stück weit noch und
nutzen die Gelegenheit über lützerat
hinaus und da gibt es durchaus ein paar
ernstzunehmende Themen auf die wir
hinweisen müssen an der Stelle denn es
gibt ernst zu nehmende Hinweise darauf
dass wir im Moment auch auf den nächsten
Extremismus gucken müssen weil es eben
in der großen großen Masse der wirklich
guten engagierten Leute die sich zum
klim engagieren ein paar gibt die im
linksextremen Rand unterwegs und
versuchen tatsächlich diese Proteste zu
unterwandern das ist durchaus ein
Problem und es muss deswegen
angesprochen werden weil es die guten
Bemühungen der klimaaktivisten
diskreditiert und ich will das deswegen
in den Mittelpunkt stellen weil wir uns
hier deutlich nochmal sagen müssen dass
wir das alles sehr demokratisch anhand
rechtsstaatlicher Grundsätze
organisieren müssen dass die Texte der
letzten Generation in akzeptabel sind
wenn sie erpresserischen Charakter haben
an der Stelle und das ist eben einige
anarchische Extremisten gibt die sich
zufälligerweise jetzt zu wenigen Tagen
in meinem Wahlkreis im Mülheim an der
Ruhr und niedergeschlagen haben vor
einer Schule wurde ein Auto eines
Bauunternehmens in Brand gesteckt mit
verweist eine anarchischen Gruppe auf
lützerath darüber hinaus Aufrufe zu
Anschlägen gehen in die Breite dort und
das ist ein Thema was wir nicht einfach
wegschweigen können wenn sondern was wir
offensiv adressieren und diskutieren
müssen weil wir es gerade eben nicht und
rechtsauslegern hier überlassen dürfen
über extremistische
antidemokratische Bestrebungen hier zu
diskutieren das tun wir ganz gelassen
und sehr objektiv aus der Mitte des
Parlaments dafür brauchen wir sie nicht
und die Sicherheitsbehörden haben das im
Auge und ich will deswegen einen kleinen
Appell am Ende noch mal loswerden und
will sagen die guten und engagierten
Menschen die sich zum Klimaschutz
engagieren kleine Fußnote ich würde mir
wünschen sie würden sich auch der
Umweltkriminalität etwas näher annehmen
weil das ein Thema ist was wir hier aus
dem Parlament noch mal intensiv nach
oben bringen was wirklich ein impact hat
auf die klimaerwarmung und den Rückgang
der Artenvielfalt und ich rate wirklich
dazu sich diesen
Gewalttätern und verfassungsverhalten zu
widersetzen und diese unter dieser
Unterwanderung gegen zu treten ist
diskreditiert die gute Klimabewegung und
die Schließe mit einem guten Satz von
oder die Fabio der beim Neujahrsempfang
des bundesjustizministers ein sehr
klugen und weißen Satz gesagt hat der
trivial ist aber sehr sehr zutreffend
ist wer Steine auf Polizisten und
Polizisten wirft der wird sie auf die
Demokratie und letztlich auf uns alle
Sebastian Fiedler aus der SPD-Fraktion
in dieser aktuellen Stunde die auf
Antrag der afd-zustande gekommen ist
Sebastian Fiedler ist Kriminalbeamter
war sehr lange sehr aktiv im Bund
Deutscher Kriminalbeamter nächster
Unionsfraktion und Mitglied im
Rechtsausschuss letzten Jahres gefassten
Beschluss dass durch den vorgezogenen
Kohleausstieg in NRW diedorfer
keilenberg Kuckum oberwestrich unter
Westrich und berberath und die drei
feldhöfe eggeratterhof Holzhof und
Weiherhof erhalten bleiben war aber auch
gleichzeitig klar dass lützerath im
Tagebau weichen muss das war das
Ergebnis der Vereinbarung von
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck und NRW
Wirtschaftsministerin Neubauer in mit
RWE wir im Kreis Heinsberg freuen uns
darüber dass nun die oben genannten
Dörfer und die feldhöfe bleiben obwohl
über 90% der Menschen in den Neuendorf
von Wohnen und die allermeisten Häuser
leer stehen und natürlich dadurch kann
man diese Vereinbarung kritisieren und
auch dagegen demonstrieren aber bitte im
Rahmen des rechtlich erlaubten und
letzteres ist insbesondere am
14.01.2023 nicht geschehen Aktivisten
haben zur Gewalt gegen Polizeikräfte
aufgerufen organisierte Aktivitäten der
Aktivisten wollten gezielt Polizisten
angreifen verletzen und sich so gegen
den Rechtsstaat wenden es flogen Steine
Flaschen
Molotow-Cocktails und Pyrotechnik
gezielt in Richtung der Polizisten
dass das Zitat wurde mir jetzt gerade
schon vorweggenommen aber oder die Fabio
beschreibt es in der Tat auch so wer
Stein auf Polizisten wirft wirft Stein
auf unsere Demokratie und dagegen muss
sich der Rechtsstaat und die Demokratie
zur Wehr setzen dies ist durch den
Polizeieinsatz in lützerath in
verhältnismäßiger Art und Weise
geschehen die Polizei hat eine intensive
kommunik Situation mit den Aktivisten
sowohl vor als auch während der
Räumungsarbeiten geführt die Polizei hat
nicht nur hat nicht nur Flächen für
Demonstrationen zur Verfügung gestellt
und ausgewiesen sondern auch
hergerichtet und damit gerade bei den
feuchten Witterungsbedingungen für eine
ausreichende Befestigung gesorgt die
Presse wurde jede Berichterstattung
ermöglicht es haben im Vorfeld
Informations- und diskussionstermine
stattgefunden um bereits vor den
Maßnahmen Fragen zu beantworten und
Anregungen und Besorgnisse aufzunehmen
die Polizei hatte zudem eigens
kommunikationsbeamter eingesetzt wenn
dann die Aktivisten der aggressiv
versuchen sich der Allgemeinverfügung
und den Betroffenen Beschlüssen zu
widersetzen so muss die Polizei
einschreiten schließlich hat sie auf die
Aktionen der Aktivisten reagiert und
musste leider mit zunehmend deutlicher
Zeit musste mir zunehmender Zeit
deutlicher reagieren um Recht und
Hoffnung durchzusetzen im Innenausschuss
der Innenausschuss im Landtag von NRW
kommt in seiner gestrigen Sitzung
fraktionsübergreifend einstimmig zu der
Bewertung dass die Polizei im gesamten
Verlauf des Einsatzes richtig gehandelt
hat zum gleichen Ergebnis kommt der
Hamburger polizeiwissenschaftler Raphael
Behr der die Einsätze der Polizei stets
genauestens analysiert und sie auch
nicht mit Kritik verschont die
Anschuldigungen der Aktivisten sind
bisher nicht belegt wir müssen als
gezielte Falschmeldungen bewertet werden
selbst die angebliche lebensgefährliche
Verletzung einer Person ist nicht belegt
von den 14 in Krankenhäusern gebrachten
Personen waren fünf Polizisten die
schlimmste Verletzung war lediglich eine
gehirnerschüttung der Einsatz im
lützerat wird von der Polizei NRW als
schwierigsten Einsatz bewertet diesen
Einsatz in der durchgeführten Art und
Weise zu bewerkstelligen gebührt große
Anerkennung ich bedanke mich daher bei
dem Aachener Polizeipräsident
vereinsbach und allen Polizistinnen und
Polizisten für ihre hervorragende Arbeit
zu Verteidigung unseres Rechtsstaates
was den Aktivisten jedoch ziemlich egal
ist ist wie sich die noch in den fünf
Dörfern wohnenden Menschen fühlen die
Aktivisten verbreiten dort auch jetzt
noch Angst sie tun so und wollen das Sie
beachten nicht die Rechte der Bewohner
bedrohen sie beschimpfen sie und erheben
den Anspruch nun mit den fünf Dörfern
machen zu können was sie wollen wenn man
weiß dass hinter den Aktivisten die
linksradikale
intervenationistische linke steckt so
kann man sich ausmalen was dabei
herauskommt der Einsatz in lützerat ist
nun beendet die Menschen in fünf Dörfern
wollen in Ruhe leben sie wollen keine
Aktivisten vor Ort haben über 90 Prozent
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger wohnen in den
neuen Dörfern die entsprechenden Häuser
stehen leer die verbliebenen wollen ihre
Dörfer wieder lebendig machen und
revitalisieren das ist das gute Recht
dieser Menschen andere wie Aktivisten
haben kein Recht sich hier vermischen
und die Dörfer für ihre Ziele zu
instrumentalisieren die Stadt Erkelenz
wird in kürzer einen offenen Plan zum
Beteiligungsprozess starten
sich Bund und landbeteiligen müssen
damit die fünf Dörfer wieder sich
entwickeln können und in eine positive
Zukunft gehen können vielen Dank
Wilfried Oellers für die Unionsfraktion
sagt die schlimmste Verletzung war eine
Gehirnerschütterung na ich glaube ich
würde da nicht tauschen wollen selbst
wenn das die schlimmste Verletzung bei
diesen Demonstrationen und
gelegentlichen Ausschreibung war jetzt
ist Wilfried oerler noch massiv ermahnt
worden übrigens vom Bundestag viel zu
Präsidenten bezüglich der Einhaltung der
Redezeit dabei ist der Bundestag
eigentlich ganz gut im Plan im Vergleich
zu dem was sie ursprünglich vorgesehen
waren Lukas Benner ampult mit dem
Rechtsausschuss Mitglied bei Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und er kommt aus
Aachen also aus der Gegend von blitzerat
unsere ganze Region ist geprägt durch
die tagebauten hinten Hambach und
Garzweiler als ich klein war meine
Eltern immer gesagt das sind die
wolkenmaschine die machen das Wetter
aber wir müssen anerkennen dass sich die
Realität gewandelt hat heute erzählen
Eltern ihren Kindern nicht mehr die
romantische Geschichte von der
wolkenmaschine sondern heute ist allen
klar braunkohle ist ein absoluter
Klimakiller
vor diesem Hintergrund ist es klar dass
ich es als Erfolg sehe dass wir den
braunkohleausstieg im Rheinischen Revier
auf 2030 vorgezogen haben man kann das
kritisch sehen man kann auch diskutieren
und vor allen Dingen kann man einfordern
dass das nicht ausreicht aber für unsere
Region ist das eins ein Schlussstrich
für die Verstromung von Braunkohle im
Rheinischen Revier und wenn wir einmal
zurückschauen auf den März 2022 dann hat
RWE gerade da das Urteil von dem Ufer
die Münster erhalten dass die letzten
Grundstücke in nützerath Eigentum von
RWE sind in dieser Ausgangslage kommend
haben wir es hinbekommen gemeinsam mit
NRW den Braunkohle ausstieg um 8 Jahre
vorzuziehen fünf Dörfer und drei Hufe zu
retten das muss man als Erfolg
deklarieren
aber und das möchte ich an dieser Stelle
so deutlich sagen das reicht nicht für
das 1,5 Grad Ziel das reicht nicht für
alle unsere klimabeümmung und das reicht
auch nicht sehr hinzustellen und zu
sagen wir haben es geschafft aber die
Aufgabe die vor uns steht ist die
planungsbeschleunigung ist mit den
Erneuerbaren Ausbau voranzukommen denn
das Ziel muss doch sein dass die Kohle
unter lützerath nicht verfeuert wird
weil jedes Windkraftrad jede
wasserstoffanlage ein Beitrag dazu
leistet dass es sich nicht mehr lohnt
bei all dem Protest in und um nutzerrat
möchte ich noch einmal sagen dass ein
Großteil der Menschen vor Ort absolut
friedlich gegen Braunkohle demonstriert
hat diese Demonstration den Inhalt und
das Ziel dass wir mehr gegen die
Klimakrise tun teile ich teilen wir und
ich glaube Teil der Großteil von ihnen
auch aber wenn wir uns anschauen was in
lützerath passiert ist dann muss man auf
der einen Seite sagen dass ich sehr froh
bin dass der Innenausschuss des Landes
NRW sich auch die schrecklichen Bilder
vom Samstag angeguckt hat dass der
Landtag von NRW da eine Aufarbeitung
macht
denn das was danke Herr Krings das was
wir gesehen haben war im ersten Moment
schockierend ich möchte aber auch sagen
an dieser Stelle dass auch das was von
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten rund um
lützerath passiert ist angesprochen
werden muss in der Nacht zum Donnerstag
voriger Woche wurden die Scheiben meines
Wahlkreisbüros in Aachen eingeschmissen
dort wo wir sonst gemeinsam für Ziele
kämpfen wie wir gegen die Klimakrise
angehen wo wir für demokratische
Mehrheiten kämpfen und wo wir immer
offen waren für den Diskurs lang
die Ehrenamtlichen die sich engagieren
sind eingeschüchtert und beängstigt von
der neuen Art der Aggression
die Worte die zu hören waren auch von
Teilen der AktivistInnen Aktivisten war
Verrat und Widerstand ich möchte hier
einmal aus der Süddeutschen zitieren
Widerstand leistet man gegen
Unrechtsregime wenn Widerstand geboten
ist dann ist jedes Mittel recht im
Streit um die Umsetzung politischer
Ziele ist das die falsche Kategorie auch
weil sie den keinen der Eskalation in
sich trägt
ich möchte sagen wer zum Widerstand
aufruft der benutzt ein Mittel was die
Demokratie zur Verteidigung von sich
selbst in unser Grundgesetz gesetzt hat
wer die Grenze zu täglicher Gewalt
überschreitet der verliert unser aller
Solidarität man kann Gerichtsurteile
kritisieren man kann sie für falsch
halten und ja unser Rechtsstaat hält es
auch aus wenn man sich der Polizei in
den Weg setzt und friedlich weggetragen
wird aber der gewaltanwendet der
verlässt den politischen Diskurs und uns
alle zumindestens diese Hälfte dieses
Hauses macht doch aus dass wir für die
bessere Idee streiten
und die bessere Idee für den Diskurs und
für ein Miteinander
ich bin in der Voreifel groß geworden
und aus meinem Fenster sich immer noch
die Kühltürme des Kraftwerks weißweiler
und wenn ich mir vorstelle was 2014
jemand sieht der aus diesem Fenster
guckt dann wünsche ich mir dass man
Windenergieanlagen sieht dass man sieht
wie wir Strom aus Wasserstoff gewinnen
wie wir Strom aus Sonne ziehen und wie
wir es hinbekommen haben das NRW die
erste klimaneutrale Industrie Region
Europas ist machen wir uns auf den Weg
vielen Dank Lukas Bernhard aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die grüne nee kommt
aus der Region Aachen hat auf ein
Problem hingewiesen dass die Grünen im
Moment haben mit
klimaaktivistin da gibt es einen
ausgeprägtens in diesen Zeiten den den
Aktivisten geht die Politik der Grünen
nicht weit genug in Sachen Klimaschutz
Janine Wissler für die Linksfraktion
meine Damen und Herren die Klimakrise
bedroht durch Naturkatastrophen Dürren
und Hunger das Leben und die Existenz
vieler Menschen vor allem im globalen
Süden und auch hier sind wir mit den
Folgen längst konfrontiert erinnern wir
uns an die flugkatastrophe im Ahrtal an
die Berichte zur Trinkwasserknappheit im
Sommer an die vielen hitzetoten in
unseren Städten an die ausgetrockneten
Flüsse und die Waldbrände ganz Europa
der Klimawandel ist eine existenzielle
soziale Frage und wissenschaftlicher
fakt ist es bleibt nur noch sehr wenig
Zeit um umzusteuern darum geht das und
das muss man sich vor Augen halten wenn
wir heute darüber diskutieren dass im
Jahr 2023 ein Dorf abgebaggert wird um
die darunter liegende Braunkohle
abzubauen dort wurde ein Windpark
abgerissen um weiter Kohle zu fördern
und das obwohl Studien belegen dass die
Kohle unter Lutzerath gar nicht
gebraucht wird für die
Versorgungssicherheit das ist Protest
und warum das alles weil die Ampel weil
sich die Ampel und die schwarz-grüne
Landesregierung und NRW den
Profitinteressen von RWE offensichtlich
stärker verpflichtet fühlt als im
Klimaschutz und da haben sie auch gar
kein Problem Menschen zu enteignen an
anderer Stelle Pranger sie das sehr an
es waren Bundesländer
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck und die NRW
landeswirtschaftsminister Neubauer beide
Mitglieder der Grünen die den
vermeintlichen Kompromiss mit RWE
ausgehandelt haben vor der NRW
Landtagswahl waren die Grünen lützerath
und haben alle Dörfer bleiben skandiert
heute verteidigen sie das Abbaggern und
reden sich raus mit dem Argument RWE
habe ja das Recht dazu abzubaggern wenn
das so ist stellt sich die Frage warum
haben sie das den Leuten nicht vor der
Wahl gesagt warum sind sie nicht nach
Lutzerath gefahren haben gesagt alle
Dörfer bleiben es sei denn er wie
besteht darauf sie abzubaggern
und was ist denn mit den rechtlichen
Verpflichtungen zur Einhaltung der
Klimaziele was ist denn mit dem
internationalen Abkommen wie das Pariser
Klimaabkommen was ist denn das für sie
ist das eine unverbindliche Empfehlung
ist das was woran man sich so lang nur
so lange gewunden fühlt bis es irgendein
Konzern stört bei internationalen
Konferenzen zeigt die August Ministerin
mit dem Finger auf andere aber
Deutschland baggert Dörfer ab für Kohle
blockiert die Verkehrswende sie halten
die Klimaziele auch nicht ein alle
sollen Energie sparen aber es gibt immer
noch kein Tempolimit und die Zahl der
Flüge mit Privatjets sind auf einem
Rekordniveau und da hilft das doch nicht
dass die Grünen das Jahr 2023 zum Jahres
Klimaschutzes erklären wir retten doch
das Klima nicht durch schöne Worte
sondern durch entschlossene Taten meine
Damen und Herren und dann loben sie den
Kompromiss mit RWE weil der Ausstieg aus
der Braunkohle vorgezogen wurde aber
aber entscheidend für das Klima ist doch
nicht einfach nur das Ausstiegsdatum
sondern wie viel CO2 bis dahin noch in
die Atmosphäre geblasen wird und
kurzfristig darf RWE doch jetzt erstmal
mehr Kohle verfeuern und aus der
Vergangenheit wissen wir doch auch dass
ausstiegstermine auch ganz gerne wieder
gekippt werden wenn es gerade passt und
offenbar geht auch RWE fest davon aus
noch weit über 2030 hinaus Kohle
verfeuern zu können rWE will nämlich ein
Reserve Lager von 50 Millionen Tonnen
anlegen für die Zeit nach 20 30 so ist
es nämlich nachzulesen in der Antwort
des NRW Wirtschaftsministeriums auf eine
Anfrage einer grünen
Landtagsabgeordneten und das
Ausstiegsgesetz der Ampel sieht ja
ausdrücklich vor dass man die Reserve im
Jahr 2026 noch mal prüft wer auch immer
dann regiert Glückwunsch ganz toller
Kompromiss und da kann ich gut verstehen
dass die Aktiven dass sie sich verraten
und dass sie sich verarscht fühlen das
kann ich gut verstehen und ich bin sehr
froh dass die Fraktion DIE LINKE
geschlossen gegen diesen Deal mit RWE
gestimmt hat weil das Problem bei den
Grünen ist dass Sie nicht bereit sind
sich für den Klimaschutz mit Konzern
Interessen anzulegen auch mal mit dem
eigenen Koalitionspartner anzulegen und
das kenne ich aus Hessen wissen Sie die
Woche wurde der Fechenheimer Wald in
Frankfurt geräumt soll gerodet werden
für ein Autobahnausbau und da sitzen die
unmittelbar Verantwortlichen nicht im
Konzernzentralen auf die man ja keinen
Einfluss nehmen kann nein hier ist der
Bauherr der Bund und Grüne tragen das
mit im Bund in Hessen und in Frankfurt
ob es um die Energiewende um den
Flughafenausbau oder die
Automobilindustrie geht wenn es wirklich
ernst wird zeigen die Grünen ein
Rückgrat wie Wackelpudding und das ist
das Problem meine Damen und Herren
ich war
ich war letzte Woche in Lutzerath ich
habe im Camp übernachtet ich war bei
Aktionen und Sitzblockade ich habe dort
Menschen getroffen die sich um das Klima
und kommende Generationen um die
Demokratie sorgen die sich mit dem
Bauern in der Region zusammengetan haben
und den Anwohnern die friedlich für eine
liebenswerte Zukunft kämpfen
sozialgerecht mit zukunftssicheren
Arbeitsplätzen meine Damen und Herren
diese Menschen sind keine
klima-terroristen wie die AFD behauptet
sie sollten sich sowieso erstmal die
Terroristen in ihren eigenen rein
kümmern die waren klimakomben die waren
Klima Terroristen das sind die die
illegal Wälder im Amazonasgebiet
zerstören das sind die die indigene und
umweltschütze die sich gegen Raubbau an
der Natur engagieren am Morgen lassen
227 Umweltaktivisten sind allein im Jahr
2020 ermordet worden dass meine Damen
und Herren ist Klima Terrorismus
Kollegen wunderbar
Präsidentin die Räumung von Lutzerath
konnte nicht verhindert werden aber die
klimaerwegung hat neue Kraft getankt und
noch ist die Kohle im Boden es ist
höchste Zeit die Notbremse zu ziehen
vielen Dank
sagt Janine Wissler für die
Linksfraktion aber sie ist ja auch
Vorsitzende der Partei Manuel Höferlin
ist der nächste Redner in dieser Debatte
in dieser aktuellen Stunde in der es um
lützerath die Demonstrationen und die
Reaktion der Polizei geht auch um
Ausschreitungen die es phasenweise immer
mal wieder gegeben hat Manuel Höferlin
ist innenpolitischer Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion in den letzten Jahren und
Monaten hat in den Eindruck gewonnen
dass etwas sehr Wichtiges
auch in dieser Diskussion wieder
Vergessenheit geraten ist nämlich
Demokratie und Rechtsstaat indem wir
leben die Regeln unseres Zusammenlebens
und die Regeln wie wir gemeinsam zu
Entscheidungen kommen finde ich sind die
besten die wir je hatten ich kenne
jedenfalls kein besseres System zu
Entscheidungen gemeinsam zu kommen als
das was wir jetzt haben meine Damen und
Herren dazu trägt unter anderem ganz
wesentlich die Meinungsfreiheit des
Demonstrationsrecht dazu bei dass auch
in Deutschland zu Recht besonders
geschützt ist jeder kann seine Meinung
in diesem Land vertreten jeder kann für
seine Anliegen demonstrieren und es
spielt keine Rolle ob er eine Mehrheit
vertritt oder ob er einen Minderheit
vertritt oder ob eine einzelne Meinung
vertritt auch die kann er äußern jeder
kann für seine Überzeugungen auf die
Straße gehen und sich Gehör verschaffen
und so kommen in unserem Land auch
politische Entscheidungen zustande denn
auch dort werden Meinungen gehört
Standpunkte mit einbezogen und all das
mündet in einen Kompromiss den am Ende
die Mehrheit der Menschen mittragen kann
und mit dem am Ende auch alle
Betroffenen leben müssen meine Damen und
Herren das ist unser System das sind die
Regeln die wir uns gegeben haben und
auch nach diesen Entscheidungen kann
jeder noch seine Meinung vertreten auch
nach diesem Kompromiss kann jeder auf
die Straße gehen und demonstrieren und
kann im Rahmen unserer Möglichkeiten
sagen wofür da nicht einverstanden ist
und dieser Mechanismus hat uns zu einem
der freisten und faisten Länder der Welt
gemacht aber eben dieser Mechanismus
meine Damen und Herren ist in letzter
Zeit sehr stark unter Druck geraten
in den letzten Jahren übrigens auch
während der pandemiezeit in erheblichen
Maße und jetzt auch aktuell bei
denonstrationen in Lutzerath steht
nämlich nicht mehr eines im Mittelpunkt
der Konsens sondern der eigene
Standpunkt die eigene Meinung wird
absolut gesetzt und die Kompromisse
werden nicht mehr als Gewinn für die
Gesellschaft sondern als persönliche
Niederlage empfunden und dann passieren
die Grenzüberschreitungen mit denen wir
jetzt in lützerath aber davor auch schon
anderen Stellen immer wieder
konfrontiert werden der es wird versucht
dass der eigene Standpunkt weil er
absolut gehalten wird mit allen Mitteln
durchgesetzt wird und ich finde vorhin
gut erklärt die der die Notwehr die dort
gegen den Staat
vorangebracht wird und ich vorgebracht
wird die ist da um sich gegen den
Unrechtsstaat zu werden gegen den eben
nicht die Meinungsfreiheit existiert
indem nicht der Rechtsweg offen steht
das ist bei uns aber genau nicht der
Fall und dann schlägt diese absolute
Meinung um in Gewalt und diese rote
Linie meine Damen und Herren die dürfen
wir auf keinen Fall zulassen
der
Rechtsstaat ist hier gefordert der
Rechtsstaat ist gefordert dort wo Steine
und molokows gegen Wolfsburg Cocktails
gegen Polizisten fliegen dort wo diese
roten Linien überschritten werden und
egal wie nobel oder einleuchten für den
Einzelnen sein Motiv sein dieser
Grundkenntnis unserer Gesellschaft dass
wir eine friedliche Konfliktlösung im
Inneren in unserer Demokratie haben der
darf nicht überschritten werden und
derjenige diejenigen die dagegen
widersprechen die das verstoßen die das
aufkündigen die dürfen nicht auf mildere
Umstände hoffen egal wie sehr derjenige
diejenige sich in Recht sieht und
welchen Zielen er sich verpflichtet
fühlt
und daher ist es auch ein Bärendienst
der diese Person für die Mehrheit der
Demonstrierenden leisten denn die
Mehrheit der Demonstrierenden gehen ja
friedlich auf die Straße und wollen
friedlich ihre Meinung vertreten und
und es ist deshalb umso wichtiger dass
diejenigen die dort friedlich ihre
Meinung und tun die demonstrieren gehen
ganz genau hinschauen mit wem sie dort
Hand in Hand gehen und das ist die
Verantwortung derjenigen die unsere
Systeme zur meinungsäuterung und zum
Demonstrationsrecht nehmen zu schauen
dass sie sich auch dieser Überquerung
der roten Linie entgegenstellen dass sie
sich klar abgrenzen davon dass man diese
Regeln mit Füßen tritt und Gewalt gegen
Polizisten Polizistinnen anwendet und
deswegen müsste heute auch nicht über
Gewalt in lutzerat sondern über
Klimaschutz gesprochen werden aber wir
tun es genau wegen diesen Chaoten nicht
und eines ist mir noch wichtig zu sagen
die Polizistinnen und Polizisten die den
Rechtsstaat und die Demokratie
verteidigen die haben unseren Dank und
unsere Rückendeckung im besonderen Maße
verdient denn oft wird auch vergessen
dass dort wir stehen unsere Gesellschaft
die wir Menschen die wir aus unserer
Gesellschaft dahingestellt haben jeder
Polizist ist eine Mutter ein Vater eine
Frau eine Schwester die am Abend auch
wieder nach Hause gehen möchte und diese
diese Bruch brachiale Gewalt und der
Hass die unseren Vertretern für
Demokratie und Rechtsstaat entgegensteht
ist für mich unerträglich und das ist
auch absolut unverschämt den Menschen
gegenüber und wollen uns gesagt worden
da stecken Menschen dahinter und das
sollte man am Ende nicht immer vergessen
herzlichen Dank
Gaming politische Sprecher der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion Manuel Höferlin
war das in dieser Debatte die die AFD
beantragt hat zur
den Ereignissen in lützeratung dazu
jetzt aus der afd-fraktion Reinhard
Kraft
[Applaus]
ja geschätzte Präsidentin Werte Kollegen
zuerst ein kurzer Realitätscheck wir
sind auch schon derzeit Wind am Netz
zweieinhalb Giga Markt Cola im Netz 28
Gigawatt so viel zur Frage ob wir die
Kohle brauchen Frauen Nestlé ja
blitzrad hat gezeigt dass die grüne
Unterwanderung gestartet ist sehr weit
fortgeschritten ist selbst ernannte
Klimaschützer sind als grün sie stehen
einem Polizei gegenüber die von dem
grünen Polizei-Chef geführt wird der
Interessen einer grünen Landes und einer
grünen mitgeführten Bundesregierung
vertritt und flankiert wird das ganze
von Grün unterwanderten Medien des
öffentlich rechtlichen
die Grünen haben sich diesen Staat zur
Beute gemacht ja und auch genau deswegen
steht es so schlecht um unser Land
neben den klimatterroristen die
Molotow-Cocktails Böller und Steine auf
Touristen werfen oder geschossen haben
waren auch sogenannte parlamentarische
Beobachter der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen vor Ort
Abgeordnete dieses Hauses haben sich mit
den Kriminellen solidarisiert und als ob
das nicht schon Skandal genug war ist es
so dass sie genau diese Abgeordneten
nämlich hier namentlich für die
Abbaggerung von lützerath gestimmt haben
sind aber zur Falke zu ihrer eigenen
Entscheidungen zu stehen
liebe Kollegen sie stimmen hier dafür
und demonstrieren da draußen an der
Seite von Kriminellen dagegen
offensichtlich besitzen sie nicht den
Charakter und das Rückgrat zu ihrem
eigenen Wort zu stehen aber
Aufrichtigkeit aber Aufrichtigkeit wäre
kann ich noch nie eine grüne Tugend
Bundestagsabgeordnete gegen die
Konsequenzen ihres eigenen
Stimmverhaltens demonstrieren
dann die legitimiert das unsere
Demokratie das Signal ist nämlich ganz
klar was davon gesendet wird blockieren
die Klima Terroristen nur genug Straßen
und Flughäfen inszenieren die Berufs-
und Neubau nur genug Fotoshootings
erzeugen
klima-jüdin und predigen die
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien nur oft
genug den Klima Weltuntergang ja dann
können auch 14,8 Prozent der Grünen am
Parlament vorbei Deutschland ihren
Willen aufzwingen
[Applaus]
manipulative Propaganda Lügen Fake News
Panikmache und Gewalt sind die Mittel
der Wahl der Klimabewegung und Wohlstand
Freiheit und Demokratie das sind die
Opfer der grünen Politik
aber gehen wir einen Schritt zurück geh
meinen Schritt zurück warum eigentlich
wird lützelrath abgewaggert formell
wegen der Abstimmung hier im vergangenen
Jahr und durch Gerichtsentscheid
bestätigt aber notwendig wurde es durch
den 14 Juni des Jahres 2000 genau da
haben nämlich SPD und Grüne den Aufstieg
Deutschlands aus der zivilen Nutzung der
Kernenergie beschlossen als Folge wurden
21 Gigabyte sichere preiswerte und das
ist ihnen ja allen immer angeblich so
wichtig CO2 Arme Leistung komplett
vernichtet die Folge war klar
Deutschland muss mehr braun und
Steinkohle und auch Gas verfeuern für
die Stromerzeugung 4 Hamburg Moorburg
und so weiter und so weiter
über diese Kohlekraftwerke ist schon 40
heute die Grünen aber wegen des
Atomausstieges wurden sie einfach
notwendig
wir stellen fest erstens lützerath muss
weichen weil sie die dümmste
Energiepolitik der Welt betreibt
und zweitens die Zehntausende von
Windrädern die Millionen von
Solarpaneelen die seit 2000 mit den
Damen verbundenen Kosten von mehreren
100 Milliarden Euro in Deutschland
aufgepflanzt wurden sie konnten
lützerath nicht retten
[Applaus]
Kernkraftwerke hätten das gekonnt und
hätten
für alle denen das angeblich immer so
wichtig ist zu einer signifikanten
Senkung der CO2-Emission in Deutschland
beigetragen
die Alternative für Deutschland
vollbringen kann ich nicht ihren
co2-ideologie aber den anderen
Fraktionen ist das nach eigener Aussage
ja angeblich immer so wichtig und der
Herr habe ich mal eine Frage an Sie
die Einsparungen die sie auf dem Gebiet
noch vorzuweisen haben sind
homöopathisch und der Fortschritt in
ihren Bemühungen zur CO2 Minderung
bewegt sich derzeit mit der
Geschwindigkeit eines Gletschers
wäre es jetzt nicht mal an der Zeit die
Methode zu hinterfragen sie zu fragen
warum das nicht so funktioniert wie sich
das vorgestellt haben in den
Nachbarländern das besser machen mal zu
schauen wie die das machen
aber das machen sie natürlich nicht und
warum weil sie glauben dass sie es
besser wissen ja physikel der Spruch und
als sie das Ziel auf den Augen verloren
verdoppelten sie die Geschwindigkeit
lützerath ist ein Fanal der deutschen
Klimabewegung die ganze Welt hat gesehen
wie die biologisch verblendet sie sind
und das ihnen Recht und Gesetz sowie die
demokratischen Entscheidung dieses
Hauses egal sind wir als Alternative für
Deutschland fühlen uns aber aus innerste
Überzeugung dem Spruch über den Portal
dieses Gebäudes verpflichtet
Durchschnitt aber nicht für das
Weltklima dort steht dem deutschen
Volker
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Jan plobner das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
sehr verehrten Kolleginnen der
demokratischen Fraktionen ich sags wie
es ist mir geht's glaube ich wie den
meisten hier im Saal dass wir hier schon
wieder mit solchen Beiträgen der AFD
rechnen uns auseinandersetzen müssen das
strengt mich wirklich wirklich sehr an
aber so durchschaubar dieses Manöver
auch ist möchte ich dennoch erklären
warum die AFD das mit dem rechten Staat
auch heute wieder bewusst missversteht
zwei Themenkomplexe bei denen es auf
erstaunliche Weise immer wieder zu ganz
schön viel Verwirrung kommt der
Rechtsstaat und der Protest gegen
unzureichende Klimaschutzmaßnahmen es
ist zwar ein wenig ernüchtern sich immer
wieder mit den gleichen Manövern
auseinandersetzen zu müssen aber gut wir
sind ja in einem Rechtsstaat dafür
führen wir diese Debatte und versuchen
ein wenig Klarheit in den Zusammenhang
zwischen diesen beiden drei
Themenkomplexen zu bringen obwohl das
allein der Fakt dass wir uns hier so
viel Blödsinn von sich geben können und
wir uns das anhören müssen eigentlich
ein guter Hinweis darauf sein könnte
dass es um Demokratie und Rechtsstaat
bei uns gar nicht so schlecht bestellt
ist dann ist das doch auch ein Zeichen
Helmut Schmidt sagte mal ich zitiere mit
Erlaubnis der Präsidentin der
Rechtsstaat hat nicht zu siegen er hat
nicht zu verlieren er hat zu existieren
aber auch eine spontane Google-Suche
nach der Definition des Rechtsstaates
würde ergeben ich zitiere auch da wieder
mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin Regierung
und Verwaltung sind nur im Rahmen
bestehende Gesetze Handeln
verhandlungsfähig die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger werden so vor staatliche Willkür
Diskriminierung und
Menschenrechtsverletzungen geschützt
Rechtsstaat bedeutet also dass den
BürgerInnen ein transparenter
rechtmäßiger Umgang durch den Staat
zusteht und dass der Staat sich an Recht
und Gesetz hält dabei kommt uns
Repräsentantinnen des Staates natürlich
eine ganz besondere Verantwortung zu
allen Bürgerinnen gleich weit und fair
zu behandeln der Protest gegen
unzureichende Klimaschutzmaßnahmen ist
in erster Linie nämlich genau das ein
Protest dass wir die
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen brauchen und mehr
davon das steht für mich außer Frage
aber wissen Sie was selbst wenn ich
andere Meinung wäre selbst wenn ich
nicht an die wissenschaftlich belegten
Fakten glauben würde selbst dann müsste
ich damit leben dass es Proteste gibt
wir leben in einem Rechtsstaat und
natürlich dürfen Menschen dagegen
protestieren wenn Sie das Gefühl haben
die Regierung hält sich nicht an Recht
und Gesetz und missbraucht ihre Mehrheit
dann werden sie beim Zweifel auch von
der Polizei gegen dafür bestellt
beschützt das ist wahrscheinlich eine
der größten Errungenschaften die wir als
Rechtsstaat erreicht haben und das ist
wohl eine der größten Unterschiede zu
starten bei denen wir bei denen Menschen
von der Polizei niedergeknüppelt
gefoltert und ermordet werden wenn sie
sich gegen Unrecht erheben
wir können uns also darüber streiten ob
mit Schlamm zu werfen schlimmer oder
genau das gleiche ist wie mit Steinen zu
werfen wir können uns darüber streiten
ob wir es angemessen finden im Stau zu
stehen weil wir auf der Straße vor uns
sich jemand angeklebt hat worüber wir
und das sage ich bewusst wir uns nicht
streiten sollten ist eine Verstärkung
des Strafrechts gegen spezifische
Gruppen und die vorderteilung des
klimaprotestes als Klima mitsamt
vorbeugender Präventivhaft und ohne
jegliches Gerichtsverfahren
und dazu schaue ich auch mal kurz zu der
CSU und der Union als Abgeordneter aus
Bayern fällt es mir nicht schwer da
passende Beispiele zu finden denn auch
die CSU scheint immer mal wieder eigen
welche wortführungsstörungen beim Thema
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu haben gerade in
dieser Woche wenn wir vom Schurken stark
die Rede ist bezüglich andere
Wahlrechtsreform also schauen
also schauen wir mal kurz nach Bayern
dort gibt es ein sowieso schon komplett
fragwürdiges polizeiaufgabengesetz wo
die CSU vor der Landtagswahl im Länder
des in 2018 mit aller Macht das
durchgedrückt hat darin die Möglichkeit
Präventivhaft anzuordnen und zu
begründet es die CSU terroristische
Straftaten vorzubeugen was die CSU dann
aber tatsächlich macht ist
klimaaktivistinnen sich auf der Straße
festkleben über Weihnachten Weg zu
sperren und das weil es schlicht das
Bild passt dass die CSU kurz vor der
nächsten Landtagswahl zeichnen möchte
eine Idee auf die sich von der AFD
natürlich liebend gerne aufspringen
solche Anwendungen Wandlungen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen untergraben den
Rechtsstaat das gefährlich und das ist
besonders hier das müssen hier besonders
Viren Auge behalten deshalb betone ich
anschließend und abschließen und auch
ganz bewusst das ist richtig und gut ist
dass auch da schaue ich jetzt auf die
Seiten der AFD diese Prinzessin ihre
ehemalige Fraktionskollegin und wieder
für andere vermeintliche
reichsbürgerinnen entfernen
rechtsstaatlichen Prozess erleben werden
ein Prozess in dem sie einen anwand an
ihrer Seite haben womöglich sogar
mehrere einen Prozess dem Argumente
Paragraphen und Beweise gegeneinander
abgewogen werden ein Prozess für dessen
Ende immer auch die Möglichkeit eines
Freispruches steht weil sie diese
Vorwürfe sich nicht belegen lassen es
ist gut dass wir einen Rechtsstaat haben
und in diesem Leben und im Zweifel auch
solche Debatten über Dinge führen die
ich eigentlich für selbstverständlich
erachte vielen Dank
jan plobner war das aus der SPD-Fraktion
mit ein paar verweisen in Richtung
Bayern der Bundestag diskutiert über
lützerath einem Angriff auf den
Rechtsstaat so nennt es die afd-fraktion
die diese aktuelle Stunde beantragt hat
und der nächste Redner ist Michael
Breilmann aus der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen also es
ist ja viel Unruhe hier bei der AFD ich
möchte Ihnen nur kurz sagen ja von einer
Partei die als Verdachtsfall durch den
Bundesverfassungsschutz eingestuft werde
von denen brauchen wir keine Belehrung
zum Thema Rechtsstaat inklusive
und ich möchte jetzt zu Beginn einiges
klarstellen es ist gut und richtig gute
und richtig dass Menschen in unserem
Land öffentlich für ihre Anliegen
demonstrieren können das ist ein ganz
wichtiges Grundrecht aber und das sollte
jeder diskutiert noch relativiert werden
das geht nur friedlich im Rahmen der
Gesetze und im Rahmen der Absprachen
zwischen Polizei und Veranstaltungen da
haben sich auch viele Demonstranten in
lützerath gehalten aber ein großer Teil
leider nun mal einmal nicht und das muss
benannt werden da muss das Konsequenzen
geben und das muss auch geachtet werden
ich will aber auch sagen die Rechtslage
in lützerati war und ist völlig klar die
Allgemeinverfügung zur Räumung sie war
rechtmäßig und im übrigen auch über alle
Instanzen hinweg bestätigt
und wenn wir dann anfangen als
Gesellschaft
Urteile Beschlüsse von Gerichten in
Zweifel zu ziehen und Anliegen einer
Gruppe über diese Urteile über diese
Rechtsprechung über das Gesetz zu
stellen dann wäre unser Rechtsstaat am
Ende und das dürfen wir als Parlament
nicht zulassen
und die Räumung
die Räumung dort die Räumung dort nicht
will den Blick da auch auf die Arbeit
der Polizei richten die war kein
Alltagseinsatz Nordrhein-Westfalen wurde
in der räumungsphase durch Kräfte fast
aller Bundesländer und des Bundes
unterstützt in der Spitze waren bis zu
3.700 Kräfte eingesetzt das war für alle
Beamtinnen und Beamten hochkomplex und
äußerst schwierig und deswegen großes
Dankeschön an alle Einsatzkräfte für
diese länderübergreifende Zusammenarbeit
und die kluge und kommunikative Arbeit
und das will ich auch sagen weil er ist
verantwortlich auch mit dafür auch danke
für das höchst besondere handeln von NRW
Innenminister Räumen auch das muss man
mal sagen wenn der Einsatz gut gelaufen
ist das muss man ja auch mal betonen
und ich finde wir sollten vielleicht
jetzt nicht über Hambach reden sondern
vielleicht mal den Blick auf die dort
befindlichen in lützerath befindlichen
und arbeiteten
Polizeibeamtinnen und Beamten richten
ich finde das sollten wir nämlich hier
im Parlament mal ein bisschen genauer
tun
es gehört dazu diese Ausnahme Situation
zu beschreiben ja da flogen Steine
Flaschen Molotowcocktails und es wurde
mit Pyrotechnik auf Einsatzkräfte
geschossen da wurde zum Teil aktiv dazu
aufgerufen von Störern die Anweisungen
der Polizei zumindest achten und völlig
fassungslos bin ich dass es Aktivisten
gab die sogar mit ihren kleinen Kindern
in Lutzerath an die Abbruchkante
gelaufen sind obwohl die Polizei vor
akuter Lebensgefahr in diesem Bereich
gewarnt hat da waren teilweise
dramatische gefährliche Situation es ist
gerade im Ansatz angesprochen wurde es
wurde zum Beispiel bewusst durch Störer
die Pferde der Reiterstaffel Scheu
gemacht da wurde von Störern mit großen
Rettungsdecken
auf die Pferde zugelaufen mit großem
Gebrüll und Getöse ein Pferd ist dann
tatsächlich durchgegangen und ist auf
die Abbruchkante zu galoppiert mit der
Reiterin auf dem Sattel diese
Polizeibeamtin hat er noch versucht das
Tier zu beruhigen und einen
ungefährlichen Bereich zu führen
letztendlich hatte sie keine Wahl als
abzuspringen und dann hat auch
glücklicherweise das Pferd gestoppt die
Masse an Störern die stand drumherum die
hat gejault und die hat applaudiert weil
da eine Beamtin zu Boden gegangen ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen da gibt
es nichts mehr zu relativieren und dann
müssen wir den Beamten und Beamten den
Rücken stärken als Deutscher Bundestag
wir müssen die schützen
und ja es erscheint mir dann befremdlich
wenn Kolleginnen der grüne nutzerath als
Beobachter sich aufhielten und sich
später von diesen Dingen nicht eindeutig
distanzierten
und leider haben dies die führenden
klimaaktivisten Frau Neubauer und Frau
thumberg auch versorgt der Zweck heiligt
die Mittel das kann ich das Motto des
demokratischen Rechtsstaats sein und ich
will die klimaschutzbewegung auch nicht
unter generalverdachtstellung Gottes
Willen aber wir müssen uns Sorgen
darüber machen über extremistische
Versuche der Einflussnahme auf die dort
handelnden Akteure Organisationen und
Gruppierungen und im lützerat haben zum
Teil linksextremist sie will
demokratische Kräfte vereinnahmt das ist
vom Verfassungsschutz bestätigt worden
und da müssen wir den Blick darauf
halten abschließend möchte ich betonen
die Polizei lützerath das ist auch schon
angeklungen sie stand für uns alle ein
und das demokratisch gesetzte Recht
durchzusetzen rechtsfreie Räume werden
wir als cdu/csu-fraktion weder ein
nutzerrat noch an einem anderen Ort in
Deutschland tolerieren
Michael Michael Breilmann für die
Unionsfraktion in der Diskussion über
Geschehnisse in lützerath in den
vergangenen Tagen als es um die Räumung
des bereits geräumten Dorfes also von
seinen ursprünglichen
ursprünglichen Bewohnern ging Ingrid
Nestle ist am Pool sie ist vorhin schon
mal angesprochen worden hier in dieser
Debatte von Rainer Kraft dass er
afd-fraktion jetzt die Erwiderung frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ganz schön blöd jetzt haben sie
gerade gesagt von der
rechtsaußenfraktion der AFD ich würde
auch sagen ganz schön blöd für Sie
die größte terroristische Gefahr in
westlichen Nationen geht von extremen
Rechten aus das sagte das sagte niemand
geringeres als der
UN-Generalsekretär Antonio gut herrisch
ja die ganze un ist so eine linke
Organisation das zeigt ihr Verständnis
von Demokratie und das das ist die
einzige Erklärung dafür warum sie von
Rechtsaußen heute diese aktuelle Stunde
anberaumt haben und dann in ihren Reden
nichts anderes zu tun als mitbegriffen
wie Terroristen und potenziellen Mördern
ein völlig absurden Kontext um sich zu
werfen sie wollen davon ablenken was sie
Ware die größte terroristische Gefahr
der westlichen Welt ist wie ist Antonio
gut festgehalten hat sie wollen davon
ablenken was in ihrem Dienst passiert
was die wahre Gefahr für die Demokratie
ist sie wollen ablenken von ihrer Arbeit
die Demokratie
die Menschen verachtend ist sie wollen
ja ich rede über ihre Reden zu ihrer
aktuellen Stunde und sie meinen das sei
nicht zum Thema natürlich ist das zum
Thema sie haben genau diese Begriffe
hier in die Diskussion eingebracht und
deshalb rede ich gerade zum Thema
und es ist nämlich genau das Thema dass
sie wollen das wichtige das Begriff für
die furchtbare Verbrechen bezeichnen
dass sie sich abnutzen damit man nicht
mehr merkt was ihnen passiert
ja es gab große Proteste am Wochenende
für mehr Klimaschutz und gegen das
Abbaggern von Braunkohle
es gab große Proteste
zehntausende haben demonstriert und die
ganz große Zahl der Menschen hat
friedlich demonstriert
[Applaus]
aber ich glaube das sollte hier auch
noch viel mehr Raum einnehmen in der
Debatte die allermeisten Menschen haben
friedlich demonstriert und es gab klare
Aussagen vor Organisationen die sich für
friedlichen Protest ausgesprochen haben
sie haben friedlich demonstriert weil
sie weil sie ein sehr sehr wichtiges
Anliegen haben nämlich Klimaschutz
Klimaschutz der nach wie vor nicht ernst
genug genommen wird weil Klimaschutz das
ist was wir brauchen um
Versorgungssicherheit um Bezahlbarkeit
von Energie um sozialgerechtigkeit um
den Industriestandort Deutschland zu
werden zu gewährleisten Klimaschutz ist
das ohne dass keines unserer anderen
Ziel erreicht werden wird und das ist
das worauf sie aufmerksam gemacht haben
und das ist richtig und gut so
und jetzt Kollegin Wissler von der
Linksfraktion
auch ihre Rede hat die Wirklichkeit
nicht wiedergegeben und ich glaube
eigentlich dass sie das wissen sie haben
behauptet sie haben behauptet mitzurat
würde abgebaggert bei den Grünen die
Konzernen Interessen wichtiger werden
als der Klimaschutz
ich mache Klimaschutz seit ich Schülerin
bin ich habe
Wirtschaftsingenieurswesen Energie
studiert um diesen Klimaschutz auf die
Reihe zu bekommen ich mache seit über
einem viertel Jahrhundert klimaschutz
ist jetzt meine Leidenschaft und ich
kann Ihnen versichern wir haben für
diesen Klimaschutz 20 30 gekämpft wir
haben alles dafür gegebenen
koalitionsverhandlung am Ende kam
idealerweise raus ja und wir haben es
trotzdem geschafft den Klimaschutz den
Kohleausstieg 20 30 im Rheinischen
Revier zu bekommen
aber gehen wir einmal kurz auf die
Vorgeschichte ein gehen wir einmal kurz
auf die Vorgeschichte ein wenn Sie hier
rufen mit Tonnen
als ein Linker Wirtschaftsminister in
Brandenburg die Verantwortung trug hat
er gefordert dass die Braunkohle bis
2045 laufen soll
es gab dann es gab dann eine
kohlekommission in der hart gerungen
worden ist in Kohleausstieg vorzuziehen
da haben auch die Umweltverbände am Ende
die Hand gehoben für 20:38 Uhr weil es
ein großer Fortschritt war und wir haben
unsere ähnliche Revier 20 30
durchgesetzt und ja das ist gut so und
ja auch ich möchte mehr und auch ich
hätte am liebsten dafür zu Rad steht
aber wir kämpfen für jedes zehnte Grad
und wir kämpfen für jede Kunde brauchen
Kohle die unter der Erde bleibt
und das bedeutet und damit komme ich zum
Ende das was uns wirklich hilft am Ende
das sind die drei eh das sind
erneuerbaren Energien das sind die
Energieeffizienz und das sind die
Einsparungen und hier liefert die Ampel
wir haben den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien aber vielfach mit dem Gesetz im
Sommer wir haben es
Energieeffizienzgesetz in Arbeit und der
Kanzler hat zugesagt dass es kommt
können Sie mir aufhören zu meppenheim
schon gesagt dass ich gerade gleich am
Ende bin und wir haben immer wieder
Einsparung und dass sie von den Linken
das immer wieder lächerlich gemacht hat
uns nicht davon abgehalten denn wir
stehen für Klimaschutz herzlichen Dank
Ingrid Nestle doch ins fast ins Markt
getroffen von den Anmerkungen die es von
einigen Rednern hier vor ihr gegeben hat
in dieser Debatte über lützerath und was
ich dazu getragen hat in den vergangenen
Tagen hat sie jetzt doch reichlich
emotional auch reagiert Michael Kruse
ist ja nächste Redner aus der
FDP-Fraktion und der ist
energiepolitischer Sprecher
ein Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst
ein Wort zum Anmelder der Debatte
insbesondere zu dem Kollegen der die
Debatte heute eröffnet hat wir als
FDP-Fraktion sind auch etwas irritierter
darüber mit Kolleginnen in der Ampel
Kompromisse zu schließen und dann
festzustellen dass diese Kolleginnen
auch auf den Demonstrationen gegen eben
die Folgen dieser Kompromisse
demonstrieren aber
es gibt schon noch einen qualitativen
Unterschied zu dem was sie hier tun und
der qualitative Unterschied liegt in
folgendem Herr Hilse wenn sie
demonstrieren da gibt's davon hinterher
ein Video wie sehen Handschellen
abgeführt werden und dann werden sie
hinterher verurteilt wegen Widerstandes
gegen die Polizei und das ist glaube ich
rechtskräftig sogar das Urteil so wie
auch natürlich die ablagegenehmigung
rechtskräftig ist aber das dann eben
doch noch mal ein qualitativer
Unterschied weil wenn ihre
Parteifreundinnen und Parteifreunde in
diesem Staaten was planen dann lernen
Sie den Staatsschutz kennen weil der
kommen muss um ihren Staatsstreich zu
verhindern und deswegen meine ich sie
als Verteidiger des Rechtsstaats das
funktioniert überhaupt nicht sie sind
kein Vorbild obwohl sie Vorbild sein
sollten als parlamentarium
Parlamentarier
ich habe viele Sachen mir aufgeschrieben
die in der Debatte heute schon gesagt
wurde die werde ich jetzt überspringen
aber ein Gedanken möchte ich doch mal
mit Ihnen teilen denn es ist ja so dass
wir uns als Koalition wie noch keine
vorher um den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
bemühen und wir haben im letzten Jahr
schon eine ganze Menge an Gesetzen auf
den Weg gebracht wir werden auch in
diesem Jahr für die freiheitsenergie
noch weitere Vorschläge unterbreiten das
betrifft etwa den Bereich des äh der
beschleunigten
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung das
betrifft aus unserer Sicht auch den
Aspekt der Typengenehmigung alles
Aspekte die uns in diesem Bereich noch
mal richtig voranbringen wenn wir das
jetzt aber mal kurz als gegeben
hinnehmen nämlich dass wir alles tun in
diesem Bereich um diesen Ausbau noch
weiter zu beschleunigen dann muss man
sich schon fragen ob wir eigentlich noch
in der richtigen ausstiegsreihenfolge
sind denn wir haben wenn wir ehrlich
sind in diesem Land noch keine große
Debatte darüber geführt was eigentlich
der russische Angriff auf die Ukraine
denn an folgendes mit sich bringt und
für uns ist eine eine zentrale
Schlussfolgerung dass man hier schon
über die ausstiegsreihenfolge auch
diskutieren kann
der Wirtschaftsminister der ja heute ein
weiteres lng-terminal eröffnet dazu
gleich noch mehr hat die Frage den Raum
gestellt ob es sich denn hier um das
richtige Symbol handelt und ich meine
schon dass es sich bei lützerath um das
richtige Symbol handelt denn es ist ja
ein Symbol dafür dass wir mehr
Braunkohle Abbaggern als wir unbedingt
müssen wir haben in der Option immer
noch die Verlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
und damit auch die Reduzierung der
CO2-Emission in diesem Land in einem
Ausmaß wie es viele andere Sektoren
nicht schaffen können
wenn wir die fünf die fünf
funktionsfähigen Kraftwerke nehmen und
mal hochrechnen wenn die einen Zyklus
länger laufen dann sparen wir um die 325
Millionen Tonnen CO2 ein und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir als
FDP-Fraktion sprechen uns dafür aus
genau das zu tun und ich glaube mit uns
ist etwa 80 Prozent der deutschen
Bevölkerung viele haben verstanden warum
wir im letzten Jahr Notmaßnahmen
ergriffen haben Braunkohle mehr ans Netz
gebracht haben in diesem Jahr meine ich
ist die Zeit da gekommen um zu
diskutieren was wir an strategischen
Maßnahmen ergreifen und das hier wäre
eine Maßnahme die so großen Effekt hatte
wie keine andere abgesehen davon dass
sie auch die Preise runterbringen können
dann haben wir noch zwei weitere
Debatten die aus unserer Sicht zu
Ehrlichkeit dazugehören ich habe die
Eröffnung des dritten lng-terminals eben
genannt wir importieren große Mengen
fracking-gas über diese Terminals ich
freue mich dass ich alle Parteien in
diesem Hause darüber freuen dass diese
Terminals jetzt schnell an den Stadt
gehen zur Wahrheit gehört aber wir
könnten allein beim Schiefergas 20%
Emissionen sparen wenn wir es nicht
importieren aus den USA sondern in
Deutschland fördern und hier gehört zur
Ehrlichkeit dazu dass wir darüber zum
einen die Energie Souveränität steigern
die Preise in den Griff kriegen uns von
der Abhängigkeit von Ausland dramatisch
senken und gleichzeitig auch einen
ökologischen Beitrag liefern das gleiche
das gleiche das gleiche gilt für das
gleiche gilt für die Technologie der CCS
also CO2 Verpressung der 1,5 Grad
Bericht des IPC sagt wir werden diese
Technologie zum Einsatz bringen müssen
um unsere Ziele zu erreichen auch hier
wünschen wir uns Offenheit für die
Debatte in diesem Land das letzte ist
dass wir beim Ausbau der Infrastruktur
in diesem Land dramatisch beschleunigen
müssen
wenn man sich anguckt wie viele und wer
alles dabei war beim ersten LG Terminal
sich gerne auf das Foto begeben zu
müssen Wilhelmshaven der Kanzler war da
der Vizekanzler war da der
Finanzminister war da alle haben sich
gefreut dass sie erleben dürfen wie die
Entscheidung die eine
infrastrukturentscheidung die nicht nur
gefällt haben sondern sie auch noch die
Umsetzung beobachten könnten das ist
nämlich in diesem Land selten geworden
und ich meine wir sollten den vorderen
in der Regierung noch viel mehr solche
Fototermine erlauben deswegen wollen wir
den Infrastrukturausbau dramatisch
beschleunigen ich glaube auch das ist
eine Folge dessen was wir hier machen
denn dann werden wir auch noch schneller
aus dem fossilen aussteigen können weil
wir dann auch die Energiewende noch
wesentlich schneller dran bekommen
herzlichen
ich erteile dem Abgeordneten Hilfe das
Wort zu einer Erklärung nach § 30
unserer Geschäftsordnung und daher nicht
alle Besucherinnen und Besucher unsere
Geschäftsordnung dabei haben erkläre ich
auch gleich mit einer Erklärung zur
Aussprache dürfen nur Äußerungen die
sich in der Aussprache auf die eigene
Person bezogen haben zurückgewiesen oder
eigene Ausführungen richtig gestellt
werden
bitte
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin dass Sie
mir Gelegenheit geben diese
persönliche Erklärung abzugeben ja sie
haben Recht am 18.11 wurde ich
festgenommen förderlich festgenommen und
aus meiner Sicht zumindest rechtswidrig
und komplett unverhältnismäßig weil ich
war selber Polizist das wissen sie wegen
einer Ordnungswidrigkeit wegen einer
vermeintlichen wegen den Verdacht eine
Ordnungswidrigkeit zu Boden gebracht zu
werden körperliche Gewalt auszuüben und
dann in Handschellen 20 Minuten stehen
zu lassen das war aus meiner Sicht
unverhältnismäßig
was haben die in der Zwischenzeit ja
richtig der Staatsanwalt hat mir einen
Strafbefehl zugeschickt wenn Sie mich
einfach ausreden lassen würden Sie schon
wissen was ich gesagt habe gut okay nun
wissen sie natürlich wie die Gerichte in
Berlin besetzt sind vorrangig mit
ich stelle nicht den Rechtsstaat in
Frage sondern
gut
also
ich mach drauf aufmerksam habe sie auch
vorgelesen wozu jetzt hier tatsächlich
auch das habe ich auch gerade getan das
habe ich gerade versucht zu tun so und
dann ist es eben so dass in Deutschland
jedes Mal wenn der Staatsanwalt
irgendein Erlass schickt bzw einen Brief
schickt sofort die gesamte Presse darauf
aufspringt und dann habe ich irgendwann
auch eine Verantwortung gegenüber meiner
Familie die jedes Mal dann letztendlich
quasi Mitleidenschaft gezogen wurden und
an diesem 18.11 war es ein Skandal das
auf friedliche Demonstranten
stundenweise stundenlang der
Wasserwerfer eingesetzt wurden und bei
irgendwelchen anderen Krawallen wo es
dann wirklich zu Gewalt kam dass eben
nicht Also es ist so das stimmt sie
haben das richtig dargestellt aber ich
habe eine andere politische juristische
Bewertung und mit der Akzeptanz des
Strafbefehls nicht akzeptiert dass ich
rechtswidrig gehandelt habe
Carsten Hilse mit einer persönlichen
Erklärung zu einem Vorwurf der hier
geäußert worden war von dem
FDP-Abgeordneten große der aber in der
Sache zu stimmen scheint
Kollege Höferlin ich glaube auch sie
wollen gerne noch den Kollegen Ulrich
und die Kollegen
so also wir fahren fort in der Aktuellen
Stunde das Wort hat Dr Volker Ulrich für
die CDU CSU-Fraktion
und Volker Ulrich ist rechts politischer
Sprecher der CSU Landesgruppe und wenn
hier alles gut geht der vorletzte Redner
Präsident
t sehr verehrten Damen und Herren die
Rechtslage in Bezug auf lützeratis
parlamentarisch und rechtsstaatlich
geklärt worden die bundesinnenministerin
darf ich folgendermaßen zitieren mit
brennendem Barrikaden und wackeligen
Baumhäusern in großer Höhe haben
Aktivisten nicht nur sich selbst die
große Gefahr gebracht sondern auch die
Einsatzkräfte das ist verantwortungslos
Zitat Ende dem ist wenig hinzuzufügen
außer vielleicht noch dass wir dem
Polizisten und Polizisten unseren Dank
für ihren gefährlichen Einsatz Schulden
und das gilt friedliche Demonstrationen
sind ein verfassungsmäßiges Recht sie
hätten an jedem anderen Ort stattfinden
können aber Gewalt Steine
Molotowcocktails sind außerhalb dieses
Grundrechts und außerhalb unserer
Rechtsordnung wir müssen dem Rechtsstaat
und dem Polizisten unseren Rücken
stärken
Herr Kollege Hilse was sie im Bezug auf
den Rechtsstaat angeführt haben ist
inakzeptabel auch
rechtskräftige Verurteilungen sind zu
akzeptieren Herr Kollege plobner
wenn Sie hier die Voraussetzungen für
die Unterbindungsgewahrsam in einer
rechtsstaatsdebatte anführen da dürfen
sie nicht sagen dass die CSU eine solche
Strafe verhängt das ist juristisch nicht
korrekt unter Kollege Kruse die FDP
regiert mit also das was sie hier
anführen sollten Sie auch in der
Regierung versuchen umzusetzen
die Grünen haben dem Gesetz und der
Vereinbarung mit RWW am 1.12 22
Bundestag einstimmig bei einer
Enthaltung zugestimmt übrigens auch sie
Frau Kollegin Dr Nestle jetzt bin ich
aber irritiert vom Verhalten der Grünen
die Fraktionsvorsitzende Katharina dröge
will jetzt den
Polizeieinsatz aufarbeiten eine
Abgeordnete vor Ort die für die
Vereinbarung gestimmt hat hat getwittert
Argumente aller Gerichte haben
entschieden rWE hat jedes Rechte
abzubacken sind da eine
hörigkeitserklärung gegenüber einem
Konzern
Zitat Ende was hat das mit Rechtsstaat
zu tun als solche Einlassung eine andere
Grünen die auch für die Vereinbarung
gestimmt hat
hat auf Instagram geschrieben Zitat
immer noch Haaren wir zehn Meter hinter
der Frontlinie aus hier gibt es soweit
keine Bewegung mehr Zitat Ende ein
solches Zitat in zeitlicher Nähe zum
Ukraine Krieg ist nur zynisch und
peinlich sollten sich davon distanzieren
wenn also eine Fraktion im Bundestag
einstimmig dafür stimmt ist das eine
Frage des Respekts und des Vertrauens in
die Politik hinter diesen Entscheidungen
zu stehen das erwarten wir von Ihnen
aber es geht um eine Doppelstrategie die
Grünen müssen mehr Braunkohle verfeuern
und mehr CO2 imitieren weil sie sich
nicht einmal übergangsweise auf mehr
Kernenergie einlassen wollen
andererseits wollen sie eine Debatte
über polizeiinsätze führen und sich
nicht von eigenen ndbs distanzieren um
die Basis nicht zu beunruhigen für diese
Doppelstrategie gibt es einen einfachen
begriff er lautet Doppelmoral mit
Doppelmoral kann man eine Zeit lang in
einer filterblase erfolgreich sein und
Interessen geleitete Politik machen aber
die Energiepolitik der viertgrößten
Volkswirtschaft der Erde lässt sich mit
Doppelmoral nicht gestalten wie viel
Millionen Tonnen CO2 könnten vermieden
werden wenn wir bei der Stromerzeugung
für eine Übergangszeit weiter auf die
bestehenden Kernkraftwerke setzen würden
wir brauchen diese Übergangszeit in der
Strom Überzeugung warum um Zeit zu
gewinnen für den Ausbau erneuerbare
Energien für Wasserstofftechnologie für
neue Leitungen für Innovationen wir
brauchen einen Einsatz dafür dass
Genehmigungsverfahren schneller werden
dass wir in Forschung und Entwicklung
vorankommen und damit das neue Impulse
unsere Energie schneller CO2 machen und
das seien wir auch ein Satz erlaubt in
Bezug auf diejenigen die diese
Klimabewegung radikalisieren das ist ein
anliegende junge Generation dass wir
verstehen unterstützen gar keine Frage
aber jeder junge Mensch der einen Beruf
lehrt bei dem er PV-Anlagen anschließt
oder Wärmepumpen installiert tut
unendlich mehr für den Klimaschutz als
jene die sich auf Straßen kleben und
sich dafür auch noch bezahlen lassen es
geht um Respekt vor dem Rechtsstaat es
geht um Innovation es geht nicht darum
zu moralisieren sondern es geht darum
diese Klima Herausforderung anzunehmen
und positiv zu lösen es geht um die
Akzeptanz des Rechtsstaats aber auch
darum Doppelmoral in der Politik zu
verhindern herzlichen Dank
aus der
CSU-Landesgruppe also aus der
Unionsfraktion also in ganz konkreten
seinen Fall aus Bayern mit einem Beitrag
und Nina Scheer wird die letzte Rednerin
sein in dieser Debatte auf Antrag der
AFD zum Thema lützerath Angriff auf den
Rechtsstaat
die aller
Proteste in lutzerat friedlich waren und
das muss auch wirklich vorangestellt
werden weil sonst alleine der Titel
dieser Diskussion heute der Aktuellen
Stunde eine in eine falsche Richtung
führen kann das soll aber überhaupt
nicht verharmlosen dass an den Stellen
an denen eben dieser Protest nicht
friedlich war und tatsächlich Widerstand
in einer Form geleistet wurde dass man
das nur noch mit Gewalt gegen den Staat
bezeichnen kann dass dies natürlich
absolut inakzeptabel ist und zu Recht
natürlich dann auch zu Anklage gebracht
wird und vor die Gerichte gestellt wird
und die Gerichte und niemand anders im
Rechtsstaat als die Gerichte haben dann
zu entscheiden und zu bewerten welches
einzelne Verhalten wirklich strafwürdig
war und welches im Sinne des rechtsrades
dann auch als Gewalttat zu verurteilen
ist und sich eben nicht mehr auf dem
Boden des Grundgesetzes bzw auf dem
Boden des Rechtsstaat der unser
rechtstaatlichen Rahmenbedingungen beweg
und insofern ist es auch ganz klar ich
möchte auch noch mal zitieren dass jetzt
schon zweifach zitierte Zitate aber es
passt wirklich genau in diese Debatte
rein wer mit Steinen auf Polizisten
wirft der trifft den Rechtsstaat das
trifft es wirklich und deswegen muss
auch ganz klar differenziert werden dass
eben diese Gewalt das Gewaltmonopol des
Staates es liegt beim Staates muss beim
Start bleiben und das kann niemand für
sich reklamieren dass für sich in die
Hand zu nehmen
mit insofern ist es auch wichtig nochmal
an die Demonstrierenden zu appellieren
was denn ein Demonstrationsrecht das ist
ja ein Grundrecht uns Menschen an die
Hand gibt das Recht ist ein sehr hohes
Recht ein hohes Rechtsgut was auch weite
Spielräume in diesem Land hat und das
soll auch so bleiben aber deswegen ist
umso wichtiger dass man die Grenzen
aufzeigt und die Grenzen liegen eben
tatsächlich dort und das sollte sich
jeder demonstrierende gegenwärtigen das
ist um meinungskundgabe geht und nicht
darum mit Mitteln der physischen Präsenz
Entscheidungen die rechtlich legitimiert
sind umzukehren bzw das eigens
empfundene recht mit physischer Gewalt
durchzusetzen das ist nicht mehr
Meinungsäußerung und genau da endet eben
auch dass Demonstrationsrecht das in
unserem Staat geschützt ist und an
dieser Stelle hat Nina Scheer diese
Diskussion die wir hier in der
vergangenen mehr erlebt haben noch mal
ganz
prima zusammengefasst und auf den Punkt
gebracht und damit sind wir am Ende
unserer Übertragung in dieser Woche aus
dem Deutschen Bundestag es geht ja
nächste Woche schon gleich weiter
Dienstag beispielsweise mit den
Stellungnahmen von den Fraktionen vor
den Fraktionssitzungen und am Mittwoch
ist Befragung der Bundesregierung mit
dem Bundeskanzler da sollten Sie auch
wieder unbedingt dabei sein Mittwoch ab
13 Uhr